you are watching cold fusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
major technological change is happening
all around the world you can see it
everywhere but sometimes when change
happens it's actually just history
repeating this is evident in the
electric car in 1900 about 40 percent of
cars were electric 38 ran on Steam and
only 22 ran on gasoline now as we
approach the 2020s we're rediscovering
the electric car so how could the
electric car be so popular only to all
but vanish by 1935 why were most of the
first cars electric and what happened to
them in this video we'll take a look
I just want to give a shout out to
Squarespace for helping make this video
possible Squarespace is one of the
easiest ways to build a website there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever and
it's flexible the end result looks
professional and the whole process makes
building website easy if you're looking
to build your own website start your
free trial today visit
www.squarespace.com coldfusion to get 10
off your first purchase
first a little timeline of the
innovation in automobiles
the first practical electric vehicle was
built by Thomas Davenport in 1835
surprisingly this was almost 30 years
after the first hydrogen car
the gasoline engine didn't come about
until 1870 and the first production car
was in 1885 by Karl Benz Carl's company
would later be known as Mercedes-Benz
Rudolph diesel would unveil his diesel
engine running on peanut oil at the
World's Fair in Paris 19
[Music]
first few Decades of the 1900s would see
the widespread introduction of the
internal combustion engine
in a way this technology was taking on
the Baton from the steam engine in the
1800s yes steam-powered cars did exist
but unfortunately they required 45
minutes to warm up in cold weather and
needed to be topped up with substantial
amounts of water limiting their range
it had to be a better solution
the early gasoline-powered cars were
better than steam but were by no means
perfect to get them started you needed a
lot of muscle to wrestle with a hand
crank and even changing gears was a tall
task
assistant foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this wasn't to mention that they were
noisy often vibrated and Shook and
emitted an offensive odor
for these reasons electric cars were
seen as the best way forward in personal
transport
they were whisper quiet easy to drive
and required relatively little effort to
run in addition electric cars were
perfectly fit for short trips around the
city as country roads weren't suited for
cars just yet they were too bumpy and
treacherous
big names such as Ferdinand Porsche
founder of the Porsche motor company and
Thomas Edison went all in on the
electric Trend in fact Porsche's very
first car in 1898 was an electric model
known as The Loner Porsche one year
later Edison set out on the mission to
make better longer lasting batteries for
cars he believed that this form of
Transport was clearly the future so he
was determined despite many attempts he
ultimately abandons this Vision a decade
later
at the turn of the century overall the
car electric or otherwise was seen as an
expensive novelty only for the rich
there needed to be a way for the common
man to travel to and fro as he pleased
cars needed to be affordable yet mass
produced it would be a man named Henry
that would bring this into reality
Henry Ford thought hard about how cars
were produced and realized that
assembling a single car by a group of
three or four men was very inefficient
by observing the way in which meat and
Tin factories were run he understood
that an assembly system would be much
better suited this system would only
have a personal work on a specialized
part before that part moved on to the
next person down the line
with the idea of the assembly line he
revolutionized the car industry allowing
cars to be mass produced for the first
time this brought the price down to an
affordable level
by 1914 Ford was selling more cars than
all the other car manufacturers combined
a Model T sold for about 260 dollars or
six thousand four hundred dollars today
while an electric Roadster sold for
around one thousand seven hundred
dollars or forty three thousand dollars
today
there was just no electric answer to the
cheaper gasoline model T
foreign
this next part is a story that's often
lost in history it was known that Henry
Ford and Thomas Edison were very close
friends in fact Ford used to work at
Edison's Lighting Company when he
created his first experimental car in
1896. Edison encouraged Ford to pursue
this path resulting in the Ford Motor
Company in 1914 the pair were working on
an experimental electric car
here's Henry Ford in an issue of the New
York Times January 11 1914.
quote within a year I hope we shall
begin the manufacture of an electric
automobile I don't like to talk about
things which are a year ahead but I am
willing to tell you something of my
plans the fact is Mr Edison and I have
been working for some years on an
electric automobile which would be cheap
and practical
cars have been built for experimental
purposes and we are satisfied now that
the way is clear to success the problem
so far has been to build a storage
battery light weight which would operate
for long distances without recharging Mr
Edison has been experimenting with such
a battery for some time end quote
Edison's words in a 1914 issue of
automobile topics was interesting
quote I believe that ultimately the
electric motor will be universally used
for Trucking in all large cities and
that the electric automobile will be the
family Carriage of the future all
tracking must come to electricity I am
convinced that it will not be long
before all trucking in New York will be
electric end quote
so the details of what happened next are
pretty sketchy some people say that the
experimental labs for the electric cars
were burnt down in a fire others say
that the oil industry got to Ford but
the most likely explanation is that the
batteries that Ford wanted to use
weren't capable of powering an electric
car
whatever the reason eventually the
project fell apart after 1.4 million
dollars of investment around 34 million
dollars today
with no cheap mass-produced model in
sight this was the beginning of the end
for the electric car the invention of
the electric starter which gained
popularity in the 1910s took the manual
effort out of starting a gasoline car
this combined with the cheap oil of the
time all impacted the viability of the
electric car
further to this the quality of the roads
began to improve meaning that people
weren't just limited to Inner City
travel in the end it was all too much
and the superior range of the petrol car
was the final straw that ultimately led
to its downfall The Battery Technology
just wasn't there
throughout the decades many attempts to
bring back the electric car were made
perhaps none more Infamous than General
Motors ev1 in the 1990s
but as we all know today the electric
car is finally here after seeing what
Tesla has done major manufacturers such
as Volvo Aston Martin General Motors
Jaguar and Land Rover are all pledging
to go Electric
it really is funny the way things go
sometimes
[Music]
that's it thanks for watching I hope you
learned something from this video if
you've just stumbled across this channel
feel free to subscribe this has been to
GoGo you've been watching cold fusion
and until next time I'll see you again
for the next video cheers guys have a
good one
cold fusion is rethinking
[Music]
[Music]